[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire dimanche à glasgow débutera
là comme 26 laden sixième conférence sur
le climat qualifié de plus importante
depuis la conférence de paris dont on
dit qu'elle sera décisive et autant de
tirs à blanc après comme à chaque fois
qu'elle a été décevante il faut dire que
tous les chiffres vont dans le mauvais
sens on nous annonce une hausse des
températures de 3 4 degrés d'ici la fin
du siècle une élévation d'un mètre du
niveau de la mer et des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre qui continue
d'augmenter de 16 pour cent vingt ans
alors qu'il faudrait les réduire de 40%
aux grands maux les grands remèdes
certains commencent à demander que l'on
rétablisse le rationnement comme pendant
la dernière guerre mondiale sur
l'essence sur la viande sur le textile
sur internet alors pour un débattre nous
avons invité alma dufour vous êtes
chargé de campagne
extraction et surconsommation à la
fédération des amis de la terre qui
milite pour une transition vers des
sociétés soutenables
au nord comme au sud est ce qui a encore
une chance de respecter les engagements
des accords de paris c'est-à-dire
d'arriver à 1,5 degré ça ce serait
l'idéal
d'augmentation à la fin du siècle
concrètement on va pas se mentir c'est
assez mal parti puisque comme vous
l'avez dit aujourd'hui les engagements
des états ce qui est mis sur la table
par les états conduit à une augmentation
de 16 % en 2030 alors que les émissions
devraient baisser à peu près de la
moitié d'ici 2030 pour respecter ces
accords de paris et encore on parle
d'engagement et même pas dans l'helmand
vraiment respectée c'est même pas dit
que ces engagements soient réellement
respectée comme on pourra en reparler en
france aujourd'hui on ne respecte même
pas nos engagements au titre de l'accord
de paris ouais évidemment ferghana ziari
vous êtes analyste en politiques
publiques pour plusieurs think tank
plutôt de tendance libérale vous êtes le
délégué général de l'académie libre des
sciences du même vous êtes nombreux de
la société d'économie politique et vous
êtes l'auteur du livre les écologistes
contre la modernité qui vient de
paraître aux presses de la cité
penser qu' on reste encore arriver à
seulement 1,5 degré 2 l'augmentation des
températures moyennes
je souscris à la remarque de mon
interview si c'est assez mal parti pour
mon avis d'autres raisons qu'on va
développer tout à l'heure mais ce qui
est clair c'est qu'il ya aujourd'hui un
manque total de volonté politique de
mettre en oeuvre les technologies les
mesures les plus efficaces contre la
lutte contre le changement climatique et
aussi longtemps que ces réticences
persisteront eh bien je peine à croire
en effet que nous remplirons nos
objectifs tels qu'ils ont été définis
par les accords internationaux alors il
faudra revenir sur les moyens qui vous
semble vous les plus efficaces qui sont
pas forcément ceux que les autres bas en
effraie les plus efficaces charles
abeilles à louis vous faites partie des
fondateurs de la baie le b l évolution
dire comme ça un bureau d'études en
développement durable créée en 2000 il
ya dix ans donc vous y dirigez le pôle
énergie climat vous apportez aux acteurs
publics et privés les meilleurs conseils
pour accélérer la transition écologique
et avec guillaume martin vous avez co
écrit le rapport comment s'aligner sur
une trajectoire compatible avec les 1,5
degré rapporte donc publié par belle
évolution c'est encore possible le sac
de riz à l'époque c'était en 2019 encore
vous avez sorti cette étude c'était
encore possible alors c'est en fait les
choses n'ont pas tout à fait évoluer
c'est à dire que techniquement c'est
encore possible serre que si on prend
les faits scientifiques on n'est pas
encore un wagon 5 2 par contre si on
prend en compte l'acceptabilité sociale
c est impossible et du coup moi
aujourd'hui mon discours sera plutôt de
dire non on ne peut pas rester souviens
d'un goal 5 degrés et même rester sous
les deux degrés c'est un gage qui
nécessiterait de mettre des mesures
drastiques en place dès maintenant et
donc ou alors il faut plus tenir compte
de l'acceptabilité sociale
effet la pause et je pense qu'on se rend
pas compte de qu'est ce que cela
signifie en fait aujourd'hui les débats
sur l'acceptabilité sociale sur des
mesures qui sont relativement bénigne
par rapport à ce qu'il faudrait mettre
en place et le co fait c'est ce qu'on
disait dans le rapport aujourd'hui ce
sont des mesures qui en fait ont un
caractère qui est profonde profondément
inacceptable et qui va à l'encontre d'un
certain nombre de paradigme que l'on a
en tête aujourd'hui donc pour moi on ne
peut pas aller aussi vite dans une
trajectoire de réduction drastique donc
non la réponse est on dépassera les
magouilles 5 degrés ce qui a une
conséquence très importante c'est il
faut mettre en place des mesures
d'adaptation et d'une certaine manière
l'humanité en train de prendre en otage
le vivant en entier et l'emmène un peu
dans le mur voilà donc on doit avoir
cette responsabilité aussi s'intéresser
à tout le monde sur la planète moi ça
fait plus de dix ans maintenant depuis
la conférence de copenhague je me
souviens qu'à peu près à chaque fois que
j'organise ce genre de débat je demande
aux écologistes qui lutte contre le
changement climatique je leur demande
quand est-ce que vous allez parler de
d'instaurer du rationnement parce que de
toute façon ce sera inéluctable et
pendant très longtemps il me disait dans
nom va sensibiliser les gens va les
éduquer et depuis quelques temps ils me
disent tous oui c'est vrai rudi pense il
va falloir instaurer le rationnement
c'est votre cas
alors sans parler d'un rationnement
généralisée comme comme effectivement ce
qu'on fait on parle de carte carbone de
quotas carbone individuel parce
qu'effectivement alors d'aujourd'hui
l'acceptabilité là demain d'une telle
mesure est quand même assez on peut en
douter on va dire mais en tout cas ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'il ya des secteurs
qui sont extrêmement polluant
aujourd'hui est qu'il faut sinon imposer
un rationnement à l'échelle de la
personne à l'échelle individuelle imposé
nous on est pour imposer ce qu'on
appelle des quotas à la production haut
volume d'activité aux entreprises ont
fait directement aux metteurs en marché
de produits par exemple textile très
polluants sur l'aérien l'ensemble des
ong et pas que les plus radicales
demandent désormais une planification à
la baisse est donc une imposition en
fait de la réduction du trafic aérien et
c'est le cas dans plusieurs autres
secteurs en fait on arrive effectivement
l'ensemble de la communauté écologiste
arrive aussi un passé conclusion il ya
des secteurs trop polluants ou les
niveaux de production d'activité sont
trop énormes et on ne peut pas en fait
les ré enfin on ne peut pas le pas tant
de temps qui nous reste de 10 ans à peu
près que les scientifiques eux mêmes
comme un peu le moment qu'on doit pas
rater 2030 pour atteindre respecter les
accords de paris en fait les évolutions
technologiques dont on dispose
aujourd'hui dans ces secteurs l'aérien
taxi avec ses terres automobile ne nous
permettent pas de réduire suffisamment
vite les émissions en question et donc
on va être obligés aussi d'encadrer de
contraindre les niveaux d'activité on le
pense dans ces secteurs là et je vous
donnerai un exemple qui est un peu
l'essentiel si on parle d énergie
fossiles aujourd'hui si vous continuez
vous augmenter la part de nerfs vous
augmenter massivement le développement
des énergies renouvelables dans le monde
c'est très bien mais si vous continuez
en même temps d'augmenter massivement la
production d'énergies fossiles ce qui
est aujourd'hui le cas en fait vous
n'obtenez pas mathématiquement de
réduction des émissions et le cas de la
chine est absolument parlons c'est à
dire que à la fois la part la proportion
d'énergies renouvelables dans le mix
électrique
chinois total est énorme et il ya
beaucoup beaucoup augmenté ces dernières
années mais la croissance du pays qui
est fortement corrélée à sa consommation
d'énergie est telle qu'en fait ils
consomment toujours davantage de charbon
est aujourd'hui les émissions ne baisse
pas et continue d'augmenter donc c'est
pour ça qu'on peut pas avoir une
approche que par la technologie et qu'il
faut aussi avoir une approche forte de
l'encadrement du marché mais les
centrales à charbon si je me trompe pas
son responsable de 20% des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre
le problème c'est qu'elles sont toutes
en asie où la plupart qu'elles sont très
jeunes vont je crois 12 ou 13 ans
d'ancienneté donc elles sont là pour
rester encore très très longtemps parce
que les démente et ça coûterait de
l'argent et les faire fonctionner sa en
coûte très peu donc les chinois ils sont
vos amis nous disent mais attendez c'est
vous qui avait balancé vous les
occidentaux qui avait balancé autant de
co2 dans l'atmosphère depuis la
révolution et des industriels qui chez
vous date de deux ans parfois même trois
siècles c'est pas nous donc c'est un peu
fort de venir nous faire la leçon alors
que nous ça fait à peine 30 ans alors là
c'était plus un exemple parce que
justement la politique de la chine est
souvent décrite comme très volontariste
sur les énergies renouvelables au
contraire sont fait beaucoup d'efforts
dans les green tech par rapport à
d'autres pays donc c'était pour montrer
que même quand on fait beaucoup
d'efforts dans les green tech si par
ailleurs on ne ne plafonne pas les
technologies polluantes on s'en sort par
voilà c'était plutôt ça comme un exemple
évidemment il ya des responsabilités
différenciées entre les états nour pays
pour que j'arrête surchauffe centrale à
charbon mais déjà les plannings de
financement qui est demandé justement un
effort financier demandé aux pays riches
pour financer l'adaptation et la
réduction des émissions de gaz à effet
serre dans les pays du sud ça c'est
prévu dans les accords de bach et
justement l'ensemble des ong dénoncent
le fait que les états mettent pas assez
d'argent au pot commun chaque année pour
financer justement cette transition et
cette adaptation ferghana vie arrive
oui intérêt dans la premier temps je
pense qu'il faut rappeler qu'on est tous
d'accord pour
sur l'objectif de réduction des gaz à
effet de serre maintenant encore faut-il
attendre sur les moyens aujourd'hui dans
débat public vous avez au saut modo deux
discours qui s'opposent vous avez le
discours de la décroissance qui consiste
à dire que pour réduire le gaz à effet
de serre il faut nécessairement à
baisser le niveau de vie général de
l'humanité des pays du nord comme des
pays du sud et puis vous avez ceux comme
moi qui pense au contraire que la
méthode la plus juste et la plus
efficace est de miser sur le progrès
économique et progrès technologiques
pourquoi je préfère la solution du
progrès économique et technologique
d'une part parce qu'il faut rappeler que
si on lutte contre le changement
climatique
ce n'est pas pour faire plaisir à gaya
c'est bien pour assurer la prospérité de
notre espèce c'est le but d'une blaye
âge c'est le don de la terre oui c'est
pour le sait si on lutte contre le
changement climatique c'est bien pour
permettre aux êtres humains de jouir en
toute sûreté de leurs habitats tout en
bénéficiant du niveau de confort le plus
élevé possible idéalement c'est bien
dans ce sens que je considère que le
progrès économique et technologique
demeure le moyen le plus juste alors
maintenant est ce possible est ce un
mirage ou est ce possible quand on
regarde aujourd'hui des chiffres à
l'échelle internationale on remarque
qu'il n'ya pas de lien automatique entre
le l'élévation du niveau de vie et les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre je
vous prends juste un exemple aujourd'hui
un français
consomme plus d'énergie teint chinois
car sud africain ou qu'un mongole et
pourtant il les met à la fois sur le
plan territorial mais aussi en matière
d'émissions importé moins de co2 qu'un
chinois cad sud africains ucca mongols
quelle est la variable la plus
déterminante ici c'est la variable
technologique on a des procédés
industriels qui ne dépendent pas des
mêmes énergie quand vous êtes un mongol
un chinois sud africain vous êtes très
dépendant du charbon en france une
grande partie même si c'est encore très
insuffisant de notre énergie c'est le
nucléaire qui est une énergie décarbonée
qui est d'ailleurs à mon sens l'énergie
la plus crédible si l'on veut offrir à
l'humanité le niveau du depuis été
possible tout en réduisant les gaz à
effet de serre puisque c'est la seule
des moyens la seule énergie qui soit à
la froide et abonnés pilotable donc
disponible de jour comme de nuit
indépendamment de la météo et des
saisons et qu'ils aient fait preuve de
son efficacité à grande échelle or vous
voyez bien que le problème des pays
développés c'est la schizophrénie à
l'égard des mesures les plus efficaces
pour lutter contre le changement
climatique et le discours de madame
l'illustrent très bien puisque vous avez
parlé de technologies vous avez parlé
d'énergie renouvelables n'avaient pas
une seule fois prononcé le mot d'énergie
nucléaire alors qu'on sait très bien que
les investissements dans les énergies
renouvelables pour la plupart constitue
une forme de gaspillage et vous l'avez
avoué puisque elle ne se substitue pas
aux énergies fossiles d'encadrement des
années mais parce que elles n'ont pas la
capacité de se substituer aux énergies
fossiles à cause de leur intermittence
et à cause de leur faible puissance et
l'effet pervers et c'est d'appliquer
ccca chi le le le drame c'est que chaque
euro chaque moyen consacré précisément à
ces énergies renouvelables
intermittentes défectueuse incapable de
se substituer correctement aux énergies
fossiles constituent autant de moyens en
moins pour investir dans une énergie
atomique fiable qui elle serait capable
de faire baisser les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre beaucoup plus rapidement
avec un retour sur investissement
beaucoup plus fort pour chaque euro
investi et il me semble qu'ici que les
mouvements écologistes qui
historiquement pour des raisons
culturelles idéologiques sont hostiles
au nucléaire ont une part de
responsabilité dans l'incapacité des
nations a
emboîté le pas à ses technologies
puisque c'est en raison des blocages
culturels que nos décideurs peinent à se
mettre d'accord sur le fait de déployer
massivement cette énergie à l'échelle
des pays développés comme à l'échelle
des pays émergents charles adrien louis
je crois que c'était il ya deux ans le
magazine the economist rendait hommage à
pierre messmer notre ancien premier
ministre en disant que si en 1973 comme
la france tous les pays développés
avaient fait le choix du tout nucléaire
qui aurait pas eu de réchauffement
climatique alors déjà je pense qu'on
glisse un peu trop rapidement sur le
nucléaire est l'objet vrai juste
rappeler de trois éléments avant parce
que on a parlé différents éléments on a
parlé et centrales à charbon existante
en chine
ces centrales à charbon en fait vous
avez utilisé quelque chose qui atteint
intéressant c'est que tout à l'heure je
parais de l'acceptabilité sociale en
fait il aussi l'acceptabilité économique
effectivement aujourd'hui on sait que
toutes les centrales déployés sur terre
si elles émettent jusqu'à la fin de vie
prévue c'est suffisant pour dépasser les
1,5 degré donc c'est là qu'il faut
accepter de les fermer avant leur taux
de rentabilité et ça c'est un manque
d'acceptabilité économique aussi qui
vient couvrir pour la raison que je
disais ensuite jeunes et voilà c'est ça
et donc ça coûterait cher de les fermer
quand on est le vietnam ou ou la
malaisie ensuite notre ami ferghana
utilisé un argument complètement faux
puisque l'empreinte carbone d'un france
est aujourd'hui supérieur à l'empreinte
carbone moyenne d'un chinois ses basques
la chine a aussi c'est vrai on pourra
fabriquer pour ce que vous voulez les
parce que à partir du moment où on
considère que des émissions sont
importés en france 2 fait la chasse aux
red wings avaient des marchandes elles
sauront elles sont réduites du bilan il
faut regarder avec des valeurs la
moyenne et c'est tout
ensuite vous avez pris des cas
particuliers de personnes une énergie
très cas bonnets et ensuite on a le
directement sur le nucléaire qui en fait
un débat purement électrique est pas une
et rj éthique est en fait aujourd'hui en
france le sujet c'est pas est ce qu'on
fait de l'électricité nucléaire ou de
l'ex très triste et renouvelables et
c'est dans ce sujet qu on nous enferme
c'est comment on fait pour réduire les
60% de fossiles qui servent
essentiellement à se déplacer qui
servent à faire fonctionner des usines
qui servent à chauffer nos habitats et
s'éteint et donc on peut pas se poser
cette question uniquement sur sur
l'angle nucléaire versus électricité
renouvelable et d'ailleurs il hier un
rapport de rte sortait en montrant
différentes alternatives possibles le
tout-renouvelable possible plus de
nucléaire possible un mix entre les deux
possibles avec des variabilités social
économique voilà mais en montrant que
c'était finalement un débat politique de
savoir est ce que l'on fait du nucléaire
ou du renouvelable est pas un débat
technique dans le sens où l'opérateur du
réseau électrique en france aujourd'hui
pensent que les différents scénarios
sont possibles en revanche quand on
parle le plus total 2 pts 3 quel est le
plus souhaitable ou le plus efficace
mais surtout où est-ce qu'ils aient les
moyens les plus importants de m et du
coup votre question était
tout le monde avait fait la même chose
que la france des années 70 a été passée
au nucléaire en fait ma réponse c'est
dans les années 70 ce qui s'est passé
surtout c'est le pic pétrolier dans les
chocs pétroliers et les chocs pétroliers
ont engendré des manières de penser
différentes alors en france
effectivement on s'est précipité pour la
décarbonation de notre électricité moi
je pense que c'est une très bonne chose
que l'on a faite puisque aujourd'hui on
n'a pas cette épine dans le pied on est
une électricité décarbonés en france
d'autres pays par exemple aux pays bas
ont fait le choix d'aller vers un
développement beaucoup plus importants
efforts des mobilités douces
d'aujourd'hui sont cités en exemple
quand on parle de politique vélo on
pense aux pays-bas et bien effectivement
tous les pays auraient dû faire à la
fois des mobilités douze années 70 à la
fois de l'énergie décarbonée dès les
années 70 à la fois réussir à
décarbonés son industrie sauf que ça
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que l'on a fait en
europe eh bien vous avez les vikings
garder une industrie carbonées et les
pays qui ont globalement délocaliser
leur industrie donc personne n'a
vraiment réussi à décarbonés ça et puis
on aurait dû s'intéresser ça peut-être
un impensé mais au logement à réduire la
consommation énergétique des logements
donc à mieux isoler à faire tout un tas
de choses que l'on aurait pu anticiper
des années soixante dix mais qu'on n'a
pas fait puisque l'énergie étaient
abondantes sont gratuites et c'est à
aujourd'hui sur lesquels on est on est
en train de revenir aujourd'hui on
dirait que l'alternative c'est soit on
taxe toutes les émissions de co2 dans
l'atmosphère
chacun sait inclus dans le prix du
produit pour ainsi dire à chaud quand
j'achète aztèque alors immédiatement le
prix est augmentée de mes émissions de
co2 dans l'atmosphère ce serait comme
une tva qui interviendrait à tous les
niveaux en permanence dans façon on va
trouver ça très inégalitaire parce qu'à
son lama les riches continueront de
vivre comme ils vivaient ils prendre
toujours autant l'avion etc et puis les
autres en revanche pourront plus rien
faire du tout parce que tout aura
considérablement augmenté et puis
l'autre option c'est de tout ratio n'est
par exemple de diviser la consommation
de viande par trois et puis on voit ce
qu'il reste et chacun a le droit
d'attendre de steaks par mois ou tant
d'heures de vidéos sur internet par
exemple cette émission va être stockées
sur internet éternellement
ça va coûter de l'énergie ça va être
envoyé ça va envoyer du co2 dans
l'atmosphère
donc là aussi faux que ce soit payer
d'une manière ou d'une autre j'ai
l'impression que c'est entre ça et ça
que les écologistes eux réfléchissent
aujourd'hui à pas vraiment parce qu'en
fait je pense que il ya aussi souvent un
procès en irrationalité en extrémisme
qui est souvent fait en général la
plupart des écologistes politiques mais
aussi des ong des associations demandent
un mix de toutes ces choses là c'est à
dire il ya un volet sobriété
effectivement réduction des niveaux
comme je disais d'activité de
consommation dans certains secteurs et
choisir les secteurs aussi on ne peut
pas tous traités tous les secteurs de la
même manière on a le droit d'avoir des
débats de société pour savoir dans quel
secteur on s'autorise à consommer plus à
augmenter les émissions dans quel
secteur on décide de les réduire et
c'est ça c'est des choses il ya le volet
technologique parce qu'on n'est pas anti
toux et anti technologie en soit c'est à
dire qu'il ya des progrès réalisable
technologiquement parlant dans les dix
quinze prochaines années dans des
secteurs mais ça va pas l'un va pas sans
l'autre en fait il est à la technologie
la sobriété est aussi une partie
éventuellement de relocalisation est
dedans de relocalisation de la
production en europe et c'est un gars d
en fait c'est des chemins multiples mais
effectivement sur la question de la
taxation je suis contente que vous
posiez le débat parce que nous on nous
dit voilà on comme si en fait les
écologistes seraient les seuls à
admettre qu'il faudrait que les volumes
baissent et les volumes de consommation
notamment d'énergie fossile baisse en
réalité tout le monde l'admet les
politiques néolibérales libéral
l'admettent puisqu'en fait sont en
discussion en ce moment même au niveau
de l'union européenne des taxations sur
le carbone que ce soit sur le carbone
l'essence utilisée par les voitures ou
licence utilisée pour le chauffage donc
si on met cette accession en place c'est
bien pour augmenter les prix c'est bien
pour la consommation réduisent il ya
deux manières en fait il ya que deux
manières de réduire la consommation de
fossiles c'est en discussion en tout cas
raisonnement mais il ya deux manières
c'est à dire soit vous augmenter les
prix comme vous l'avez dit avec un effet
soit très fort en termes d'inégalités
donc un effet social assez massue sur la
société soit vous encadrer de façon
réglementaire et vous laisser après les
acteurs on peut se débrouiller et
normalement en principe les faits
inflation sur les prix serait moindre et
vous pourriez carrément aller jusqu'aux
côtes à individu al oula vous assure et
individuel c'est le joli mot pour
rationnement ravin c'est à dire mais
voilà chacun a sa quantité de carbone
égal au départ et après les changent en
fonction des britanniques qu'ils en
avaient été les années 90 et cac accuse
- déjà il ya un marché aujourd'hui de
droits à polluer avec des quotas c'est
un show de l'attaqué
les britanniques avaient une carte
carbone ou vous et moi on aura une carte
et on aurait tant de carbone dépensé
pour se chauffer ce2 pour se déplacer
pour s'éclairer etc etc et puis quand la
carte elicia juste certes comme ça ça
s'appelle la carte bleue
on a limité dans nos achats nos dépenses
un quota voilà une politique de quotas
permet de rééquilibrer socialement
l'impact effectivement de ces politiques
là sur les gens la politique par la
taxation si elle n'est pas s'il n'y a
pas de mécanismes redistributifs fort
qui l'accompagnent comme c'est pas
vraiment le cas aujourd'hui en
négociations au niveau de l'union
européenne le fonds solidarité qui
viendraient essai de contrebalancer
l'impact d'une taxe carbone qui
augmenterait est trop faible beaucoup
trop faible s'il n'y a pas on pourrait
aussi envisager une taxation progressive
en fonction des revenus après tout les
revenus financiers du travail des gens
l'impôt sur le revenu et progressif on
n'envisage pas la taxe carbone comme une
taxe pour être progressif sur les gens
pour la rendre plus acceptable ce qui
est ce qui fait sens aussi mais la
question effectivement des quotas
apparaît comme la mesure la plus juste
l'encadrement par la réglementation
plutôt que par le prix pour s'assurer
que la transition soit efficace parce
que là vous êtes sûr qu'on dépasse pas
les niveaux fixés et qu'elle soit plus
juste alors que le problème de la
taxation c'est que au dernier moment les
gouvernements recul évidemment face à
l'explosion sociale et c'est exactement
ce qu'on a vu avec les gilet jaune
évidemment si vous faites exploser le
pays avec des inégalités qui augmente
trop c'est l'écologie à la fin qui perd
on recul sur la taxe le signal prix est
trop faible ça ne change rien aux
habitudes et on continue comme avant
alors que sinon on dirait qu'il ya tant
de litres d'essence par mois et puis
voilà c'est tout et vous en avez le même
nombre chacun veut dire ferghana diaries
je vais y revenir sur ce qui vient
d'être dit
il est vrai qu'il ya aujourd'hui un
consensus sur la nécessité d'apposer au
carbone un prix alors les niveaux ne
sont pas consensuels mais on estime
voilà qu'il faut quand même un prix du
carbone mais à prix de l'émission du
cardin a pris de l'émission ce gr cannes
aujourd'hui vous cachez vous pouvez
envoyer autant débit sans fin ça l'est
déjà plus guère parler à priori
d'envoyer du carbone dans la pêche a
rappelé la logique de ce genre de
mécanisme c'est à dire que c'est ça
l'idée d'un prix de 2 mètres un prix aux
externalités négatives c'est une idée
qui remonte un économiste prêter il
s'appelle arthur cecil pigou et d'août à
l'époque on estime en effet qu'il faut
mettre un prix sur la pollution pour non
pas réduire dans l'absolu les
consommations et le niveau de vie des
populations c'est pas ça l'idée d'un
prix sur la pollution c'est l'idée de
rendre moins compétitifs les
technologies et les usages polluants par
rapport aux usages vertueux donc si
demain par exemple il existe une
technologie alternative qui permette un
niveau de vie au moins aussi élevé que
celui ci nous les quotas c'est sur le
moins aussi ou non mais le problème
c'est qui encore une fois il ya une
schizophrénie en europe qui consiste à
dire qu'on va mettre un prix au carbone
c'est très bien mais qui consiste à
saboter des alternatives les plus
vertueuses puisque en europe le rappel
l'allemagne en premier a commencé à
fermer des centrales nucléaires la
belgique de faire la même chose en
france on ferme face au nein pour donner
des gages à quelques yazalde à quelques
ayatollahs verts et donc on met un prix
sur le carbone ce qui a pour effet
logique est recherchée d'augmenter le
coût de la consommation de tous les
produits d'abonnés et en même temps on
empêche l'émergence des substituts plus
vertueux et on revient donc à la
question de l'acceptabilité sociale si
vous augmentez le coût de la vie parce
que vous avez donc imposer un prix
légitime à la pollution et qu'en même
temps vous sabotez des attaques natives
les plus vertueuses vous n'avez
absolument à rien gagné et on voit ici
que dans ce cas-là l'environnement n'est
pas votre priorité c'est à dire qu'il
s'agit simplement
de de réduire le niveau de vie des gens
pour le plaisir mais c'est à dire que fo
le plan environnemental ça n'a aucune
valeur ajoutée d'où l'insistance sur le
fait que ses politiques
environnementales ne sont crédibles que
si encore une fois on valorise et qu'on
empêche pas des technologies les plus
crédibles d'émerger et je reviens sur
les contradictions la suite du mouvement
écologique puisque vous parlez du fait
que vous n'étiez pas en ti technologies
alors vous je ne sais pas mais tout
l'écosystème écologiste en france il
faut quand même le rappeler est hosted
en matière énergétique à la solution la
plus crédible pour lutter contre le
changement climatique quels atomes un
bon avant la pause ça réveille à louis
françois ancien de toujours à l'atome
avant le
juste c'est pourquoi je rabâche le sujet
c'est pas pour rien faire pour oeuvrer
pour être le perroquet simplement si
vous n'avez pas d'atome vous n'avez pas
d'électricité fiable abondante et
décarbonée donc vous ne pouvez pas
électrifiée massivement les usages
industriels individuel donc vous ne
pouvez pas électrifier les transports
donc vous ne pouvez pas envisager la
synthèse des carburants de demain on
parle aujourd'hui d'une filière
hydrogène alors pourquoi pas mais si
c'est pour synthétiser l'hydrogène à
partir de procédés pour lyon c'est pas
la peine donc il faut bien
c'est pas la tome la question c'est si
vous n'avez pas une énergie primaire si
vous n'avez pas un système électrique
robuste après ce procès se pose à quai
et les narbonnais mais c'est la seule
qui existe en soit ça soit
dans sa cavale
là on va faire la pause on y reviendra
après effectivement on sortira de
l'énergie parce qu'il ya d'autres
questions qui se posent
[Musique]
et si la prochaine crise financière
venait de chine evergrande c'est le nom
du géant chinois de la construction un
géant qui pourtant croule sous une
gigantesque dette tout va dépendre de la
façon dont l'état chinois va gérer la
chose est ce que il sauve les détenteurs
d'obligations en interne et qui plante
les détenteurs d'obligations
externe ou est ce que il règle la note
pour pour evergrande il suffit
quelquefois d'un maillon en pull my on
est gros plus c'est risqué d'un maillon
qui sautent dans cette chaîne pour avoir
des effets de propagation globaux dit
effet boule de neige nous sommes dans un
régime de prix administrés par les
banques centrales donc si vous voulez
200 milliards c'est rien pour une banque
centrale
donc si elle veut régler le problème
evergrande demain et puis les autres
d'ailleurs un suffit qu'elle fasse
tourner la planche à billets et
aujourd'hui on est en train de tout
régler comme ça
[Musique]
ce personnage affreux tronics vous
l'avez créé en 2014 dans un but précis
montrer une autre image du continent
africain définitivement c'est d'essayer
de partir des racines des retours de
chez nous est montré que les jeunes
africains la génération peut aussi se
projeter dans le futur cela représente
quoi pour vous la ferez futurisme comme
on n'a pas eu une influence sur
l'histoire sur le passé on s'est dit on
peut se permettre d'imaginer un futur où
l'afrique serait un grand continent il
ya pas moins de se développer sans la
culture malheureusement ce qui sort du
pays j'ai la preuve que les médias
s'intéressent plus quand il s'agit de la
guerre donc à travers ma musique je veux
inviter les gens à venir découvrir ce
beau pays toy
[Musique]
et
en prend on reprend ce débat avec alma
dufour des amis de la terre avec
ferghana ziari l'auteur des écologistes
contre la modernité avec charles adrien
louis ii chez b l évolution on va
oublier un peu les énergies pour pour un
moment parce que si on doit se mettre à
rationner et beaucoup qu'ils pensent il
va falloir commencer à se mettre ça dans
la tête il va falloir rationner quand
même dans beaucoup beaucoup de domaines
et pas seulement dans l'énergie va
falloir limiter les constructions neuves
par exemple il va falloir limiter les
surfaces des habitations il va falloir
limiter la température dans les
appartements il va falloir chercher pour
résoudre et simplement limiter la
surface de nos jardins privés oui alors
je vais revenir sur un terme qui est
utilisée c'est qu'on parle beaucoup de
niveaux de vie en fait moi je parcours
beaucoup les territoires je vais
dans le cadre de mon métier à la
rencontre des gens on ne parle jamais de
niveau de vie dans les territoires on
parle de qualité de en fait ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on oublie un peu au
niveau politique gendrey débat on veut
toujours augmenter le niveau de vie en
fait les gens ce qu'ils cherchent c'est
garantir une certaine qualité dû se dire
ça ça passe pas forcément par l'achat ou
par ce genre de choses alors après quand
on parle de rationnement en fait la
question c'est quel est le niveau juste
et équitable et donc du coup on peut
parler du logement on peut aussi parler
des biens de consommation aujourd'hui
est ce que c'est juste et équitable que
on consomme plusieurs dizaines de
nouveaux vêtements neufs chaque année
par français 42 vêtements neufs par par
français et par an dont un quart ne sont
jamais portés par les personnels et les
achète on porte des vêtements jetables
en fait ce que je tube là il n'est pas
fait pour durer toute ma vie comme
l'étaient les costumes de mon grand père
c'est un visa il les sommets plus
aujourd'hui j'aurai quelques adéquat on
revoir quelques mois pour la plupart des
vêtements et c'est là en fait on peut se
demander qu'est la question où est la
part du besoin essentiel et oui la part
du besoins superflus donc quand on parle
de rationnement c'est diminuer un peu ce
besoin elle revêt d'autres des chiffres
je crois que c'est sur les vôtres
chalayan oui en fait si on voulait te
dire dans pour les 1,5 degré il faudrait
qu'on puisse acheter grosso modo quoi un
kilo un kilo et demi de vêtements neufs
par année bush par alvaro débarrasser la
france voilà c est en gros 5 kg 1 kg de
vêtements neufs 9 ce qui n'empêche par
eux d'aller dans les friperies ce qui
n'empêche pas de faire des échanges de
frein il ya énormément de manière
ouverte on peut toujours avoir une forme
de mode tout en portant des vêtements
qui ne sont pas forcément
il n'y a pas de après les chiffres que
j'ai donné moi ce sont des chiffres qui
disent si on est sérieux et qu'on veut
vraiment et c'est sous les 5 degrés en
fait c'est ça le bon ordre de grandeur
après à chacun de s'interroger part ça
il ya des gens qui me disent mais très
bien moi j'achète quasiment jamais du
neuf j'achète que du recyclé dure aux
conditions du machin tout ça ça me pose
aucun problème sur ce sujet d'autres qui
disent ah bah non mais en fait moi c'est
mon activité de tous les week-ends si je
n'achète pas un frein le week-end ça
marche pas là du coup mais effectivement
dans celui des cds question qu'il faut
aujourd'hui se poser parce que presque
toutes façons on va en parler de plus en
plus donc je pense que les 1 kg de
vêtements neufs c'est un truc il faut
que l'on regarde sa norme et voir
si je peux me permettre je pense que les
taxes et c'est un exemple passionnant
parce que ça va un peu en brèche le
discours sur la mondialisation aussi sur
le fait qu'il y ait une augmentation
généralisée des niveaux de vie le
textile aujourd'hui c'est une industrie
aussi polluante c'est parce que les
niveaux de production sont absolument
colossaux donc charles adrien l'a dit
donc c'est à peu près 40 de vêtements
par habitant an dans le monde sait à peu
près 100 milliards de vêtements produits
chaque année et pourquoi autant pourquoi
autant parce que on exploite les gens
pour les pays nous en fait on sait la
délocalisation a permis aussi de réduire
les coûts de main d'oeuvre ce qui permet
en retour d'augmenter la production et
les salaires dans le secteur textile
baisse en fait depuis des années dans le
niveau mondial parce qu'il ya une course
au dumping pour aller jusqu'en ethiopie
maintenant même le bangladesh ça leur
suffit plus mais c'est aussi grâce à
d'énergie pas cher au charbon c'est à
dire que vous parlez du nucléaire vous
parlez des sources d'énergie il ya des
pays qui aujourd'hui voilà fonctionne
avec les énergies les moins chers
possibles c'est comme ça qu'on pollue et
c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne donc
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas d'égalité sur
secteur d'ici pas le monde entier ne
profite pas de l'industrie textile c'est
vraiment une production pour les pays
très riche qui exploitent jusqu'à
l'esclavagisme quand on parle des
ouigours et d'autres populations les
gens donc on peut pas d'avoir un
discours aussi général donc il ya
vraiment une question de nous ce qu'on
demande c'est pas réduire le niveau de
vie de tout le monde voilà par le
plaisir de rationaliser engageant pour
la morale après une espèce de moura qui
tomberait du ciel dont la question c'est
qu'on demande avant tout un encadrement
des pratiques les plus extrêmes des
excès les plus graves des
multinationales et une meilleure équité
est en fait une meilleure équité aussi
entre les entre les pays la ghana
diaries oui je le papier une hérédité
par personne ne pourra être être contre
contre cela ils vont mais pas toujours
les mêmes choses derrière les concepts
vous avez parlé du fait que en effet
aujourd'hui bon nombre de pays n'ont pas
accès aux énergies propres qui sont qu'
un pays comme la france par exemple émet
moins de co2 qu'une partie des pays
développés voir certains pays en
développement c'est la raison pour
laquelle me semble-t-il cette opposition
factice que l'on fait je crois assez
beaucoup trop entre transition
écologique d'une part et croissance
économique d'autre part pour moi elle ne
tient pas debout parce qu'on sait très
bien que les technologies les plus
crédibles face aux changements
climatiques sont des technologies
coûteuses s'ils vont nécessiter beaucoup
d'investissement des investissements
colossaux qui ne sont pas à la portée de
tout le monde et donc vous ne réalisera
pas ses investissements colossaux dans
un contexte de rationnement de
décroissance ou de baisse généralisée du
niveau de vie ça implique des pays
suffisamment riche pour où justement
dépenser suffisamment d'argent pour ses
technologies la
pauvre puis par des pays d'afrique par
exemple n'ont pas se restreindre pour
arriver aux objectifs de l'accord de
paris mais justement eux doivent se
développer mais comment comment se
développeront t-il si précisément on est
dans une dynamique de décroissance et de
refus des technologies les plus
crédibles j'ajoute aussi que l'impératif
de l'adaptation puisque on parle des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre mais
il ya aussi l impératif de l'adaptation
qui n'est pas suffisamment évoqué dans
les médias elle aussi infirme si vous
voulez l'utilité de la décroissance
puisque là encore toutes les données
montrent que les sociétés les plus
résilientes et les plus résistantes face
aux aléas naturels sont les sociétés les
plus développés sur le plan industriel
quelques exemples quand vous vous
appelez aujourd'hui israël et que vous
avez les moyens de dessaler l'eau de mer
vous avez les moyens de mettre en place
des systèmes d'irrigation développer des
pratiques agronomiques avancer bien vous
êtes beaucoup moins vulnérables aux
épisodes de sécheresse que lorsque vous
vous appelez madagascar quand vous
appelez les pays bas que vous avez les
moyens de mettre en place des systèmes
de protection côtière ultra sophistiqué
des digues d'aménager des polders des
systèmes de drainage de des eaux vous
êtes beaucoup moins vulnérable aux
inondations et la montée des eaux que le
bangladesh par exemple donc l'une des
réponses au changement climatique et ce
n'est pas la seule c'est une des
stratégies parmi d'autres consiste à
nous assurer que ces gains en résilience
devance toujours l'émergence de ces
nouveaux risques ce qui souligne encore
une fois l'importance du développement
économique à l'échelle mondiale est
entendu que le développement industriel
au 21ème siècle ne pourra pas prendre la
forme de celui du 19e et du 20e siècle
et c'est la raison pour laquelle moi
j'insiste sur le fait que l'atom jouera
au 21ème siècle le rôle que le charbon
et le pétrole ont respectivement joué au
19e et 20e si tu as beau réagir sur la
question des impacts une partie ce que
vous dites est totalement juste mais en
réalité la les impacts on le voit vont
beaucoup plus vite et vont beaucoup plus
loin ils sont en tout cas en ce moment
en train de dépasser la capacité
d'adaptation des états les plus riches
enfin je veux dire est ce qu'on peut
parler du fait que aux états unis
l'année dernière enfin là il ya qu elle
même pas la nana quelques mois ils ont
rencontré la plus grosse sécheresse
qu'ils ont connue depuis 1200 ans ils en
sont venus à rationner l'agriculture il
ya eu des questions sur
l'approvisionnement en eau qui se sont
posés le lac mid qui a acquis abreuve à
peu près 40 millions de personnes est à
moitié vide enfin vraiment je veux dire
aujourd'hui même cape town l'afrique du
sud a frôlé la roue cyr et vt moins
riches ça aurait été pire mais bien sûr
mais en fait ce que je sais que là
aujourd'hui vous parlez d'un pas comme
si on pouvait l juguler les impacts
juste par le niveau de développement
économique de certains pays
3 c'est du coup continue de faire
augmenter les émissions tâtonnons n'ont
pas tous une fois une fois la croissance
économique tels qu'un et prendra forme
au 21ème siècle ne devra pas justement
ce se générer les mêmes émissions signe
donc ce n'est pas nous mais tout accord
final a eu lieu les élections parce que
enfin pour finir sur ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'en fait là je pense qu'il ya
aussi dans le discours quelque chose
d'une variable qu'on oublie et que je
pense que dans votre discours qui
n'apparaît pas en tout cas c'est la
variable du temps parce que la
technologie c'est super dans cinquante
ans quand on parle de 2050 de la
neutralité carbone on se dit ouais on
peut imaginer plein de choses pour avoir
une croissance verte une croissance et
notre carbone il n'y a pas de problème
encore une fois ne sais pas c'est pas
une levée de boucliers de principe la
question c'est comme je les dis au tout
début de cet entretien les scientifiques
disent qu'il faut pas rater le patent
2030 ces dix ans donc on a 10 ans et si
on réduit par rapidement les émissions
on risque de dépasser des points ce
qu'on appelle les points d'emballement
climatique c'est-à-dire des phénomènes
naturels qui vont s'enclencher tout seul
et qui vont faire augmenter les
émissions quelles que soient les
réductions humaine par ailleurs et ça on
peut pas se permettre d'atteindre ces
points là parce que là on joue carrément
avec les conditions de la vie sur terre
et je pèse mes mots et je cite le
secrétaire général de l'onu quand je dis
ça donc à un moment donné pour tes
qu'une décroissance mondiale en 15 ans
et plus crédible que le fait de
continuer le développement non en fait
on est là pour dire qu'on est en train
de jouer avec les conditions de la vie
sur terre c'est sur le pacte en 2030 on
réduit par rapidement les émissions
après si on arrive pendant ce temps là à
développer les technologies suffisante à
investir et caetera et que ça reprend
c'est très bien en fait c'est pas la
question n'y a pas de problème avec ça
la question c'est que là on a dix ans et
que malheureusement va être obligé de
passer si on est crédible avec ça on est
obligé de passer par des encadrements à
la baisse de certains secteurs
clairement d'ici dix ans c'est
obligatoire et sinon mais si c'est pas
crédible socialement économiquement en
tout cas là la dure réalité de la nature
et les deux delà du climat en fait va
nous rappeler va nous rappeler à ça il y
aura pas plus de croissance si on a
dépassé les stades emballement
climatique que y en a aujourd'hui
vraiment pas et d'autant plus qu'à
partir du moment où on parle d'eux là
carrément de mettre en jeu la vie de
l'humanité sur terre évidemment à ce
moment là on a pratiquement tous les
droits d'un côté on a le droit de faire
du terrorisme parce qu'on dise aux gens
de protéger la vie sur terre et puis de
l'autre côté on a le droit d'émettre une
dictature parce que c'est pour protéger
la vie sur terre tous les jours une
telle qu'à la fin on réduira la taille
des téléviseurs et horatio dral des
heures de vidéos sur internet non
l'ailier alors la dictature économique
on pourrait se demander si on est dedans
on pas quand j'entends certains
injonction à la croissance permanente en
fait moi ça m'intéresse pas la
croissance parce que on ne sait même pas
ce qu'on mesure en fait personne ne sait
ce qu'il ya derrière je vous donne un
exemple qui pour moi et a été à ses
parents ce qui est un progrès c'est
d'équiper les ménages de machines à
laver à voir ça et ne plus faire son
lavage à la main et bassa émancipe
notamment les femmes de tâches qui sont
ardues qui sont compliqués et qui
empêchent notamment de s'éduquer
qu'est-ce qu'on a besoin c'est que tout
le monde ait un lave linge c'est pas que
tout le monde change sont un mélange
tous les trois ans or aujourd'hui la
croissance s'est changé son lave-linge
tous les trois ans c'est un mac il on a
tous un lave-linge pas tous mais
globalement le en france on équipés de
lave linge et la moitié des habitants du
monde ne le sont pas eux ils ont besoin
d'avoir accès à ces la blanche ne les
ont pas besoin et ce qu'on leur vend
c'est pas ça c'est d'avoir accès à un
lave-linge qu'on va changer tous les
trois ans où satan ou peu importe et ça
ça le problème c'est qu'on veut
absolument rentrer dans quand on a cet
impératif de l'oac de la croissance
c'est un impératif à l'obsolescence
d'une certaine manière qu'est jackson un
autre élément sur les les éléments
technologiques
en fait aujourd'hui les pays qui se
disent développer et ben en fait ils ont
développé tellement de choses qui
doivent maintenir les infrastructures et
ça c'est important et on voit ça se
casse la gueule aux états unis parce
qu'ils sont plus en capacité de
maintenir ses infrastructures et en fait
nous de voix par notre niveau parce que
l'on a développé déjà investir des
budgets colossaux dans le maintien de ce
kit existants alors investir encore des
dizaines de milliards et des centaines
de milliards pour des progrès techniques
technologiques c'est bien beau mais en
fait ça va être au détriment de beaucoup
à dire que l'on va assurer un
développement de d'ailleurs je ne sais
pas trop quoi pour quelques-uns au
détriment de l'ensemble qui va devoir
nécessairement réduire son niveau de vie
puisque c'est une variable qui qui est
assez parlante
et c'est ça les éléments que qui pour
moi sont apposées aux débats c'est
qu'est ce qu'est ce que l'on souhaite
avoir dans l'avenir les techniques les
grandes techniques et high tech
elles ont besoin de temps pour se
développer elles ont besoin de capitaux
elles ont besoin de pouvoir
être industrialisée passer à l'échelle
etc alors il ya d'autres personnes qui
réfléchissent à d'autres moyens de
continuer se développer avec des low
tech des techniques qui sont plutôt
basses plutôt économe en ressources
plutôt diffusable un peu partout on
parle d'économie la frugalité par
exemple en est on en parle dans les pays
qui n'ont pas la chance d'avoir le
niveau de développement que l'on trouve
des alternatives pour avoir accès un
certain nombre de besoins essentiels
vitaux et c est donc moi finalement la
question que je me pose c'est puisque on
est tous conscience qu'on a dépassé les
limites puisque on sait qu'on a dépassé
plus de 5 des limites essentiel de la
planète qu'est ce que l'on fait pour
sortir de notre état d'ébriété permanent
et revenir dans un peu plus de sobriété
sobriété énergétique sobriété sur nos
consommations etc on parlait de
rationnement est ce que rationnement
c'est vraiment la question en fait
aujourd'hui je vais prendre un élément
on a parlé réduire par trois la quantité
de viande e par personne alors déjà on
pourrait se poser la question est est ce
que moi j'ai 90 kg de viande par
personne et par an c'est quelque chose
qui est sain pour la santé pour tout un
tas de choses après on pourrait se dire
ben qu'est ce qu'ils regardent tous cas
dans nos politiques publiques meilleures
stratégies nationales bas carbone elle
dit qu'on va diviser par deux la
quantité de viande qui sera consommée en
france en 2050 donc en fait on a déjà
ses objectifs de réduction la question
c'est comment on y va comment il va
alors est ce que pour y aller il faut
rationner dire chacun a le droit à 30 kg
de viande par personne ou alors est ce
qu'on se dit mais on laisse un peu de
liberté il y en a qui vont plus manger
de germes du tout d'ailleurs il a déjà
qu'ils le font d'autres peut-être qu'ils
vont être à 50 60 kg etc mais
voilà on adapte chacun s'adapte sur les
comportements
j'avais comme ça quand on a voulu aider
les gens refus mois on a augmenté
considérablement le prix des sacs et des
raisons toujours avec cette valeur
économique mais j'allais revenir sur un
dernier élément aujourd'hui on ne sait
jamais puisque en gros on dit soit c'est
l'industriel qui va développer des
nouvelles technologies qui va arrêter de
faire des technologies soi c'est le
consommateur
qui va jouer son rôle de consommateur et
arrêter de consommer des choses et c'est
là qu'un oblique entre les deux mais un
certain nombre d'éléments tout à l'heure
j'ai parlé de l'obsolescence et aussi la
publicité aujourd'hui pourquoi est ce
qu'on fait de la publicité c'est pour
vendre plus de produits c'est pour
convaincre des personnes d'un besoin qui
n'est pas essentiel pour elle qu ils
deviennent essentielles aujourd'hui on
pourrait tout simplement se dire on
arrête la publicité on l'a fait sur les
cigarettes
et on pourrait arrêter la publicité sur
tout ce qu'ils consomment de la
ressource et met les gaz à effet de
serre et c est là en fait vous êtes dans
une autre alternative qui n'est pas
taxer le carbone ou rationné le carbone
mais arrêtez cette injonction à la
surconsommation à la consommation
permanente de ressources ou ferghana
ziari votre livre s'intitule les
écologistes contre la modernité je me
demande si c'est pas les libéraux qui
sont contre la modernité rien pas tout
c'est peut-être la communauté des
redites et je ne crois pas dans mon
livre je rappelle le bilan de la
civilisation industrielle et justement
je remets en question ce serait aussi un
peu déclinistes qui voudrait que la
modernité aurait constitué une forme de
2,2 de destruction de notre habitat et
on remarque en réalité que lorsqu'on
s'interroge ce récit qui ne correspond à
aucune réalité historique ou
géographique puisque aujourd'hui il faut
le rappeler les pays faiblement
industrialisés par exemple sont beaucoup
plus victimes de la pollution que les
nations développées donc c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'insiste sur le fait que
cette opposition qui est très courante
aujourd'hui entre l'embourgeoisement du
monde d'un côté et la qualité
d'environnement de l'autre elle ne tient
pas c'est à dire que on parle jamais du
fait que les pollutions au plus de
ravages dans les pays du sud que dans
les pays du nord et que si on veut
délivrer ces populations la dépollution
primaires c'est plus de développement et
non pas plus de sobriété de frugalité
qu'ils ont besoin donc je pense que ces
propos là son petit peu déconnecté des
réalités nationales dans la mesure où
vous avez aujourd'hui des centaines de
millions de gens qui aspirent
légitimement à
améliorer leur niveau de vie et que la
vraie question de société comment marier
ce désir légitime avec les impératifs
climatiques et donc vous n'avez à parler
de rationnement on est complètement on
passe complètement à côté des besoins de
ces populations là et
de l'humanité entière justement à propos
de rationnement enfin tout ce que l'on
dit depuis tout à l'heure on parle
commis parce qu'on est entre français et
quid imaginer mais c'est bien
vrai nom mais c'est soit l'échelle du
monde soirée en coton rec est ce que ce
soit l'art coton coton quand on raisonne
à l'échelle d'une consommation de
personnes individuelles évidemment on
n'est pas en train de proposer de
consommer de rationner la consommation
d'un citoyen du burundi 1 ou d'un
citoyen
justement je vais venir beaucoup parce
que ce que vous dites vous dit on à des
locales et pelé pollution touche plus
les pays du sud et c'est assez aussi
qu'on a délocalisé l'évolution est aussi
énorme non de nos industries paulhan je
suis désolé je suis souvent dans le taxi
est sur les terres rares sur les
smartphones on pourrait en parler mais
on va passer donc les plus rapides
animant ce n'est pas ça sur les
émissions de gaz sur les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre
on va pas critiquer le récit que vous
êtes en train de faire sur le fait que
oui évidemment on n'est pas contre le
développement des pays pauvres et s'est
du coup la question du rachat non la
question des niveaux de vie des pays
riches n'a rien à voir avec celle du
fait que les pays pauvres ont le droit
de continuer à se développer non mais on
va en parler mais après la question
aussi c'est que le changement climatique
aujourd'hui intervient comme une
nouvelle variable que vous avez pas là
vous me parlez d écologie d'il ya
cinquante ans dennis voilà l'enjeu
talent pour moi je vous parle d' étude
de la banque mondiale qui vous dit en
fait c'est la première fois depuis
depuis des décennies que la pauvreté
peut et va continuer a probablement
réaugmenter alors qu'elle réduisait
depuis des décennies à cause du
changement climatique
donc c'est normal aussi cesser les
chiffres de la banque mondiale ils
disent entre 68 et 120 millions d'euros
un peu plus nombreux à penser qu'on est
méga corruption la stabilité politique
certes mais
là je voudrais les chiffres isolé pour
changement climatique mais ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'en fait justement si
on réagit avec un discours nouveau une
pensée politique nouvelle c'est aussi
parce que le changement climatique ça
n'a rien à voir avec le discours qui
s'est développé ces vingt dernières
années ces 50 dernières années l'ont là
on est sur un phénomène qui est quand
même relativement neuf à l'échelle de
l'histoire de l'humanité quelque chose
qui est très brutal qui va très vite et
oui effectivement aujourd'hui non si on
laisse la croissance mondiale telles
qu'elles se déroulent aujourd'hui
continuer versement restera plus rien
pas de 10 de croissance économique tel
cas les personnes et pour le statu quo
mais est en fait trop
on est d'accord mais ne leur a pas les
mêmes causes mais quand vous dites par
exemple il faut que je revienne
là-dessus parce que ça c'est un sophisme
et pierrick qui est régulièrement
employés quand vous dites par exemple
que pour assurer le développement des
pays du sud il vaut à pau il faut
appauvrir en tout cas diminuer un peu le
niveau de vie des pays riches je suis
désolé vous faites preuve dit ici d'une
d'une méconnaissance des mécanismes
économiques
l'économie vous êtes en charge de
reproduire ce qu'on appelle le sophisme
du jeu à somme nulle qui est un sophisme
tous revenus de l'ancien régime parce
qu'à l'époque on pensait que ce qu'une
nation gagne l'autre le père et
réciproquement c'est pas comme ça que ça
marche l'économie aujourd'hui quand vous
êtes un africain pour vous apporter des
médicaments des technologies des
ordinateurs des capitaux pour investir
dans des infrastructures
d'assainissement et bien vous dépendez
aussi des capacités productives des
nations industrialisées de sorts
qu'appauvrir le nord mais c'est aussi
appauvrir le sud est réussi pour dans
les règles du jeu néo libéral ça c'est
sûr noir c'est comme on change les
règles du genre oui c'est comme ça c'est
la tradition dans cette phase
l'interdépendance et en fait socialisme
c'est à dire que le libéralisme ou pas
nous sommes nous sommes interdépendants
j'ai donc on dépend des capacités
productives de son voisin juste excusez
moi par exemple si vous pensez vraiment
que l'effondrement de l'économie des
deux économies développées par l'aco
vide a profité à qui que ce soit de
rationalisation sur une trajectoire
progressif sur dix en novlangue
nous paraît toujours de croissance et ce
que dit charles adrien s'est totalement
juste quand on parle de croissance on
mélange tout mesure quelque chose
d'abstrait écouta il ya des secteurs où
on pourrait faire de la croissance
économique en france du pipe comme
l'agriculture comme la relocalisation
gestion d'une partie de l'industrie sans
forcément augmenter les volumes et sans
créer des problèmes de pollution
supplémentaire en fait tout dépend
comment on mesurait ce qu'on mesure nous
c'est pas la question de la croissance
du clip il y aura pas forcément
d'effondrement de l'économie française
si on plafonne et compte réduire
certains usages aujourd'hui l'économie
de produits ne produit beaucoup beaucoup
moins de valeur ajoutée aujourd'hui en
france ces nouveaux usages le numérique
et c'est à qui se développe que ce qui
se faisait avant aux états unis c'est
pareil donc la croissance comme ça un
peu dans l'air ça veut rien dire sur la
question de la solidité et du
développement des économies et je vous
donne un exemple sur l'interdépendance
on travaille beaucoup sur le secteur
textile on a conscience que nos demandes
effectivement de réduction de la
consommation dans les pays riches peut
impacter très négativement les pays
producteurs comme le bangladesh etc
pour nous ce qu'il faut faire c'est sûr
d en trouver une trajectoire qui
permettent d'augmenter de façon
obligatoire les salaires dans les pays
production pour justement permettre à un
marché intérieur de se développer
permettent progressivement dans les dix
prochaines années de réduire tout en
maintenant les niveaux de vie et ça on
peut le faire l'union européenne peut le
faire elle pourrait en cause de leur nom
mais on va augmenter les salaires c'est
le réseau des logiciels du passé en fait
pour remettre les choses telles qu'elles
sont aujourd'hui
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on est en train
de changer les conditions physiques sur
la planète on est d'accord sur l'état
des lieux voilà
c'est pas une question de est ce que nos
règles de fonctionnement commune dans
une société organisée autour de valeurs
économiques
sont un saint graal qu'il faut pas
toucher ou pas c'est qu'on change
carrément les conditions de vie sur
terre quelle est la bonne réponse alors
est ce que c'est le modèle libéral il se
trouve que ce modèle là ça fait des
dizaines d'années qu'il est à la
gouvernance mondiale si on peut dire
puisque globalement les économies qui
tire le plus le monde tel qu'ils sont
cités en exemple sont dans ce genre de
format il montre son échec puisque en 40
ans les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre ont doublé puisque on n'est pas du
tout est en train de répondre bah
justement à qui la faute ceux qui tirent
les ficelles ceux qui tirent les
ficelles c'est à dire ceux qui sont au
pouvoir le reste à définir parce que
pouvoir c'est le pouvoir des
gouvernements est ce que c'est le
pouvoir s'est désolé reprise des ong est
ce que c'est le poids il se trouve que
j'ai j'ai pas trop vu de capacités des
ong ont souvent la capacité de nuisance
certaines ong qui ont fait obstacle qui
ont provoqué la catastrophe et nani
wendel en allemagne qui s'est soldée par
un échec complet avec des centaines de
milliards des lacs dilapidés dans des
énergies renouvelables pour une touche
est réputé abonnés que les français ça
c'est quand même un coup d'aidés de
certaines ong précisément hostile aux
technologies et plus crédible donc déjà
laissé le trio parce qu'il reste trois
minutes
considérer que les ong ont ce pouvoir là
et c'est très intéressant n'empêche que
aujourd'hui quelles que soient les
personnes le monde actuel les ong actuel
les entreprises actuelles les
gouvernements actuels
s'ils continuent d'utiliser les
mécanismes du passé continuent d'aller
dans le mur et c'est ce que l'on voit on
a beau dire tout ce que veut on a dit
faire des codes pouvoir inventer 1,2226
et c'est en fait la trajectoire elle
continue d'être pareil de la trajectoire
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
maintenant on sait qu'on doit l'inversé
brutalement en fait ce brutalement et
ben il est plus on attend plus on sait
que les conditions de vie vont être
dégradée derrière donc à partir du mot
d'un moment il faut raisonner avec des
idées nouvelles avec une manière de
penser nouvelle et c est pas avoir peur
de changement pavois pas avoir peur de
se dire si ge instaure ça peut-être que
ça va avoir des impacts là dessus qu'ils
sont délétères parce que je crois que
dans les mécanismes qui prennent pas ces
rencontres parce que pour modèle
économique aujourd'hui ne prend pas du
tout en compte les impacts
environnementaux puisque c'est une
donnée qui est censé être à somme nulle
mais qui ne varie pas donc on sait que
ce modèle il les faut donc pourquoi
est-ce qu'on continue de vouloir
l'appliquer à tout prix c'est cela qui
est ça qui m'interpelle aujourd'hui
c'est forcément un autre raisonnement
qu'il faut avoir à la fin de toute façon
on accusera les écologistes de vouloir
réduire nos libertés vous savez bien à
des soit de réduire d'autres notre
niveau de vie soit de réduire notre
consommation souhaite réduire de liberté
ben moi je crois que en accusant alors
déjà ce qui est très intéressant c'est
que l'on considère que ce débat c'est
forcément les écologistes lors que moi
je pense que c'est une préoccupation
globale et c'est un peu les changes que
l'on a c'est pas qu'une question
d'écologistes quoi c'est quelle solution
apporte et et à quel moment est ce que
les écologistes si on prend ce terme là
vont réduire les libertés ou est-ce
qu'on contraire et vont augmenter les
libertés et émancipée l'être humain de
sa condition a servi un système
économique dominant aujourd'hui pour moi
le débat se pose oui en fait enfin je
rappellerai les impacts du changement
climatique est ce qu'on peut parler de
liberté vraiment dans un monde dans
lequel on se dirige ou en fait même des
pays extrêmement riches vont manquer
d'eau à des moments fin je veux dire on
parle de liberté de consommer mais là on
va avoir des problèmes sur la
consommation la plus basique on parle
aussi d'un risque très fort
d'augmentation des conflits armés entre
les pays à cause aussi du changement
climatique et donc du coup pareil quelle
liberté dans des régimes qui vont se
durcir qui vont s'autorisant d'état
risée parce que justement les conditions
de la croissance économique seront
manquantes parce que l'accès aux
ressources sera plus difficile en fait
ce qu'on propose enfin ce qu'on propose
sur les questions de baisse de la
consommation est beaucoup moins liberto
gêne on va dire qu'un monde à 3 degrés
vers lequel on se dirait ou là
honnêtement nous conserver à conserver
le moindre de ses droits civiques ça va
peut-être être compliqué dans 40 ans
vraiment d'animaux ferghana diaries
écoutez je pense que si les régimes
autoritaires avait produit des résultats
intéressants matière d'environnement ça
se saurait une histoire dément
7,7 ce ce préjugé je reste convaincu
pour ma part que la solution réside dans
l'ingéniosité de la société civile dans
l'intelligence collective et que c'est
en laissant justement cette société
civile libre de créer les solutions de
demain que nous résoudrons nos problèmes
environnementaux tout simplement je vous
remercie tous les trois de voir
participer à ce débat merci de nous
avoir suivis et rendez vous au prochain
numéro
[Musique]